das ist wirklich ein riesenproblem und
bedroht unser leben vor allem wenn wir
ins krankenhaus kommen mittlerweile sind
unsere schärfsten waffen gegen
bakterielle krankheitserreger quasi
wirkungslos denn es gibt immer mehr
resistenzen und gängige antibiotika
kommen selbst gegen die harmlosen
infekten nicht mehr an eine wirklich
dramatische entwicklung und die uhr
tickt forschungsteams weltweit suchen
wie wild nach neuen wirkstoffen ein
mögliches hilfsmittel algorithmen die
wie viel versprechende moleküle
identifizieren ist das eine vision oder
kann das wirklich funktionieren jetzt
den krieg zum science fiction herzlich
willkommen
penicillin das durch schimmelpilze
produziert wird galt lange als das
allheilmittel gegen bakterielle
infektion entdeckt wurde ist von
alexander flemming und zwar durch bloßen
zufall und auch heute noch produziert
die natur unzählige wirkstoffe die uns
in der medizin von großem nutzen sein
könnten
doch solche neuen vielversprechenden
mittel wollen entdeckt werden und das
ist tatsächlich vergleichbar mit der
suche nach der nadel im heuhaufen aber
es gibt einen lichtblick vermehrt werden
bei der suche jetzt auch algorithmen
eingesetzt die molekül varianten in den
riesigen datenbanken durchgehen und mit
bereits erfassten naturstoffen
abgleichen und die uhr tickt inzwischen
haben sich resistenzen gegen alle
gängigen antibiotika fast entwickelt
selbst gegen einfache infekte kommen sie
nicht mehr an höchste zeit also schnell
und effektiv neue wirkstoffe gegen
bakterielle erreger zu identifizieren
aber so leicht ist das nicht spezielle
datenbanken können helfen
hier sind neue naturstoffe zu finden und
zwar ganz konkret mit ihren
massenspektrometrischen signaturen heißt
so viel wie aufgeschlüsselt werden die
charakteristischen daten die ein
massenspektrometer identifiziert hat
beispielsweise die atom masse sowie die
bindungsenergie der nucleus ein beispiel
für solch eine datenbank ist das global
natural products social die mps netzwerk
für viele experten eine goldmine um neue
bioaktive substanzen zu entdecken große
hoffnung setzen forschungsteams weltweit
in sogenannte peptid naturprodukte pnp
es diese sind wohl wirklich
vielversprechenden kandidaten für neue
antibiotika konkret handelt es sich um
moleküle die aus vielen proteinen
bausteinen aufgebaut sind und genau hier
ist das problem denn sie gibt es in
unfassbar vielen verschiedenen varianten
und die meisten von ihnen sind eben
nicht ansatzweise in datenbanken erfasst
doch jetzt hat ein forschungsteam von
der universität sankt petersburg einen
lösungsansatz gefunden und das ist
wirklich entscheidend die
wissenschaftlerinnen und wissenschaftler
haben einen neuen algorithmus entwickelt
der in der lage ist aus der struktur der
bereits erfassten moleküle auf weitere
mögliche varianten zu schließen
das system namens west ermittelt also
welche war
es noch geben könnte und zudem auch wie
wahrscheinlich deren existenz
tatsächlich ist und der algorithmus hat
wirklich was drauf im ersten test
identifizierte er fast zehnmal mehr
varianten vom vertrieb naturprodukten
als herkömmliche computer verfahren
zudem arbeitet das programm deutlich
schneller für die analyse brauchte der
algorithmus wenige stunden andere
bislang genutzte programme hätten dafür
also für dieses ergebnis 100 jahre
gebraucht dazu einer der beteiligten
forscher alexej kovac damit gibt uns
unsere methode einen ganz neuen einblick
in die dunkle materie der pnp
und dies ist nur ein kleiner ausschnitt
aus den vielen fortschritten der big
data und ki im medizinischen bereich
also keine der künstlichen intelligenz
wir haben ja hier schon mal darüber
berichtet der nächste schritt ist
software die aus daten lernt und sich so
selbst weiterentwickelt das will sich
beispielsweise das forschungsteam von
microsoft in seinem projekt hannover zu
nutze machen die idee computer sollen
sich zunächst einmal das komplette
medizinische wissen aneignen
im nächsten schritt sollen die ärzte
teams dabei unterstützt werden
personalisierte behandlungsmethoden zu
finden denn sie könnten für jeden
einzelnen patienten individuell
angepasste medikamentencocktails finden
statt einen wirkstoff nach dem anderen
zu testen könnten könnte intelligente
software auf grundlage der genomischen
daten der patienten die literatur nach
der perfekten medikamentenkombination
durchsuchen auf einen schlag können so
tausende von kombinationen an also sie
analysiert werden und dem ärzte-team
vorgeschlagen werden doch die
zusammenarbeit mit dem menschen könnten
die maschinen dann sogar immer weiter
dazulernen und ihre intelligenz ausbauen
aber auch andere tech giganten wie
amazon apple google oder facebook
investieren in neues personal aus den
bereichen biologie medizin und chemie
das ist ein riesengeschäft und sie
öffnen komplett neue abteilungen
zusammen mit software experten sollen
sie die großen rechenaufgaben lösen die
rechenaufgabe deren ergebnis am ende die
biologie entschlüsselt und uns
krankheiten von grund auf erstehen lässt
das ist die große vision die
medizinische datenverarbeitung dient als
grundpfeiler dieser logik die
instrumente künstliche intelligenz und
die analyse und auswertung riesiger
datenmengen innerhalb kürzester zeit das
ergebnis zellfunktionen verstehen genome
kostengünstig sequenzieren und schnell
und effektiv neue medikamente entwickeln
wir stehen also vor einer medizinischen
computer revolution wenn er als erstes
dazu und zu allen anderen themen neues
erfahren wollt dann meldet euch hierbei
whatsapp an dann erfahrt ihr vor allen
anderen vom neuesten video eben vorab
von mir garantiert ihr könnt dort direkt
in der redaktion vom krieg zum nicht
mitmachen und themen vorschlagen oder an
umfragen teilnehmen und entscheidungen
somit treffen
der direkte draht zu mir einfach hier
draufklicken und natürlich nicht das abo
mit der genau glocke vergessen hier geht
es weiter mit dafür draufklicken
resistente bakterien bedrohen die
menschheit ansonsten bis dann bleibt
dran